(upbeat music)
- Basically like you helped me
deploy massive self-awareness.
- So in the, in the two minutes here,
because that's stuff you can
kind of tell me on Twitter.
What do you need?
Like what's on your mind?
Like, what do you think?
Like what are you trying to make happen?
- Honestly, I've been
trying to think about that
and I don't know.
I'm just.
- You just want to win.
- I just want to win.
- So good.
Honestly, that's a good answer.
That's why I just asked you that
You don't need to cripple yourself.
Here's what I would tell you.
Surround yourself with good
people as much as possible.
- Yeah.
- Like that will work itself out.
Right?
You still understand?
Like, when I say good people,
I don't mean people that have
been successful necessarily.
I mean, people that are like...
- People that are good.
- Yeah and just like to the right thing.
You need to make sure that
all those people rethink that
you're coming from a place of
bringing value and patience
not trying to network in
because that's the fine line.
That everybody.
That's what we always debate
with things like this.
This is what Ross thinks about this.
What Gilbert thinks about.
Is this kid trying to just get in?
Or is this kid trying to
provide value and knows
in 13 years, that will
be beneficial to him?
You need to convince the
market lose eight players.
That it's the latter.
(upbeat music)
- How are you?
- I'm great! How are you?
- I'm fucking pissed.
(upbeat music)
- Like just know that I watch
your videos all the time.
- Thank you, man.
- You're like the most
super influential persons
in the in the world.
- Thank you, man.
What's your name, Ryan?
- Ryan.
- How about we get (indistinct)?
- Sure. Of course.
- Yeah. I did not expect this to happen.
It's crazy.
- No worries, my man.
Thank you for the kind words.
Good luck to you.
- [Ryan] Have a good day.
♪ This what I worked for. ♪
♪ Never settle for less. ♪
♪ Always want more. ♪
♪ Started straight from the bottom. ♪
♪ Went to the top. ♪
- Hey, kid!
It's a pleasure.
How are you?
- Good.
- What's your name?
- Dominic.
- Real pleasure bro.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- Yeah. Thanks for being here.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Where are you from?
- I'm from Chicago.
I flew here.
- Oh, you did?
What do you do?
- I'm a marketer and developer right now.
I work Facebook adds, Api
doing some cool stuff.
- Very cool. Now you're
going to check on the top.
- I am. Yeah. I actually
saw your email last night
I didn't get a ticket uh, I
didn't get it here anyways.
- We'll figure it out.
We'll get you in.
Is it possible to help my
friend and get a seat in the,
in the conference?
- Yeah, sure.
- Can you just figure it out?
- Uh is he registered?
- I don't think so.
- Let's give him a badge, he's very-
- Hey, we're gonna get you a badge.
- Thank you so much man.
♪ 10 Times better. Don't
know how your sound is. ♪
♪ Need to take your bullshit
back to where you found it. ♪
♪ The way you found lost from
the start that was finished. ♪
♪ Shot diminishing rapper period. ♪
♪ Fuck the sickness. Hit
in it with a Rocket. ♪
- I want to start podcasting and blogging.
Do you have any advice about.
- My advice?
My advice. I'm just going to start.
I know, you know it, you know,
everybody knows my advice
and I get why listen,
I needed to in different
areas, you just need-
- I'm scared.
- There's nothing. There's
just nothing to be scared of.
Like, like, like, you know,
it's all about who judges who,
right?
Like.
- I guess you understand because
like I'm an international
student. So like you're,
you're like the whole transition
that I have to go through
is just hard, you know?
- It's super hard, but it's
but it's binary, right?
But it's binary. It's binary either.
You do it or you don't to me, to me,
what I do with my content
is try to eliminate the fear
because the fear is the only
thing that's holding you back.
The question is for who
like from your parents,
is it from your contemporaries,
from a random person,
with an anonymous account
that leaves a comment.
The questions always hook your truth.
Like you're experiencing
something millions of people do,
which is your, you know,
this is why create a
document versus create,
speak about being a fucking
international student.
Speak about Bangladesh.
Speak about Michigan.
Speak about hacking, being a
volunteer here for this moment.
Speak about shit, speak about shit.
- This is it man, thank
you man I love you man
you've changed my life.
- How long do I have?
- 12 minutes, 30-
Is there a there's up there?
It says it? thank you.
Good morning.
I stand up here as somebody
that's obsessed with HR,
I'm obsessed with people. Look
at it as a financial offense,
because I believe in
retention and continuity,
which then is a gateway to speed,
which is then an advantage
when you compete against any
other business. Speed is the ROI.
It is the differentiator in
sports and in business speed is
what matters and continuity.
And having people stay in
a place for a long time,
leads to speed. But even more importantly,
the thing that leads to speed
and execution is when our
employees don't have to sit
at their desk and think about
politics and dumb shit, and
actually think about the work.
And the reality is all
of this. Appreciate it.
Cause that's the punchline, right?
I'll take that clap. Thank you, bro.
It's just true. It's staggering.
How much percentage of every
single employee in the world,
right this second is thinking about how
to navigate through the
political matrix versus
getting the actual work done.
You know,
we give presents on
everybody's yearly anniversary.
When you give somebody a present,
that's a fishing lure versus a
fucking $25 Amazon gift card.
You actually are speaking to giving a fuck
versus checking the fucking
box. I'll leave with this.
I was born in the Soviet union.
Let me tell you the difference
between communism and
capitalism in communism,
you put people in a box
and they play within it.
In capitalism.
We give people freedom. And
when you do something wrong,
we put you in a box.
It is flabbergasting to me
that all of your companies in a
capitalistic environment
are putting people in a box.
I know more about my
organization. Thank you.
organization because of unlimited
vacation policy and safety and culture,
because it's how I get
an indicator at a macro.
Because when you give
people unlimited rope,
you actually figure out who
they are versus what all of you
were dealing with,
which is people are navigating
through the system you've
created and you actually have
no real feel for who they are.
Thank you.
- You were amazing. Thank
you so much. Really.
- What are like the top three
traits that you look for in a
person outside of skills?
- empathy, obsessed with empathy,
empathy drives everything.
If you actually understand
the other person more or what
they're up to or why they're
driven or what their background
is. So I'm obsessed with empathy.
Gratitude, you know, I'm
fascinated by gratitude.
Like if you're actually grateful,
you're in a happy place,
like your filter is happy.
And I think if you are happy,
you're imposing that on other people.
I think it's an incredibly
important leadership skill.
It's tough to help other
people if you're not
in a good place.
Right?
- Yeah.
And then probably humility.
Right?
So I think the way we are
winning at Bayner when we win is
just,
you have the capability of
being the bigger man or woman in
every situation.
- Okay two things, one I gotta
get an obligatory selfie.
And two, do you want me to
choose to by Gary V or-?
- Oh, whatever you want
- what do you prefer, man?
- I'm either super fine.
- I'm all for bread.
- But you know, what's funny, you know,
funny was funny.
That's just another example.
Like what matters and what doesn't right.
Thought of like what,
which version of that,
like the content we talk
about is what matters. Right?
- Cool.
- The amount of time people,
people like Gary Vander,
Chuck I'm like, people love Vander.
People really have always like school.
Like it's funny that we in
America like add that like kind
of Nordic and like, it feels natural to
make it meander, always
been fascinated by that.
- we have large brands that
are in serious pain, you know,
trying to figure out, you
know, what is our culture?
How do we create, you know, messaging?
It gets complex. You start
getting more than 500 employees.
- For sure.
For sure.
But the reality is I don't
have any empathy for these
leaders that come to me and
say, I'm struggling with this.
When every decision out of her
or his mind is predicated on
hitting numbers for wall
street in a 90 day window,
like stop talking out of
both sides of your mouth.
You actually don't care about
culture, which is by the way.
Great.
But don't fucking bullshit me-
Because we're having that
conversation right now,
all your forget about what any of us say,
show me what people are doing.
There is absolutely zero
luck involved in the
Steelers, Patriots, giants.
Like this is organizational
from the top from ownership
because you know what I say,
a Bainer that's super important.
Everything's my fault.
Cause it's true. If
the chief blank stinks,
I hired chief blank.
So from quarterback to GM,
to defensive coordinator,
to the training staff, to HR,
which I think is going to
end up being a competitive
advantage,
we're going to win because
I'm going to be the owner.
And the quality of the people
is going to be extraordinary.
And if I make the wrong
choice, which I will,
especially in the beginning,
because I don't know
what the fuck I'm doing.
I will be quick to own those
mistakes and change them out.
( crowd applause)
I don't need my in-spot.
My inbox could be 419.
If you told me, I feel good about it,
so it's more that you read
it all and there's no,
there's no, no, there's no.
Right.
That's the game.
So it's kind of like, instead of like,
do my inbox go to zero, then
do yours and do logistics.
It's read my inbox.
And I noticed you've made that
switch a little bit. Right?
- And then get you to a place
where you'll (indistinct)
- Yeah being strategic about
when you clean it, right?
You didn't do it yesterday at
all, but now midday got sleep.
You know, I, who cares, I'm asleep.
I can do it. Anyway.
Nuances, nuances,
it's just such little things.
It's the little things that matter,
which don't matter at all.
Nothing matters while in
parallel, the little things.
I mean, that's just what it is, that's it?
You know, the next 24 hours
stickers, I messaged stickers
baby, Gary V I messaged stickers.
So pumped that stickers are coming.
I message iOS stickers
dropping in the next 24 hours.
Get your Gary V stickers.
or sticker, you rock.
I'm not sure what kind of
episodes is going to be for D
rock. Obviously very
early, give a keynote,
obviously around HR,
something I'm passionate
about here in San Francisco.
Now it's pretty, it's
an early flight for us.
Usually we take it a little later. So,
but I love the fact that I'm
gonna be able to crush email
for four and a half, five hours.
And you know, some of these
things are just not super sexy,
right? Like some of you
who are cynical characters,
which I feel bad for because
that's a defensive mechanism,
ask me like, what do you do, Gary V like,
it seems like you just go and talk.
And they're in meetings all
day for all youngsters that are
razzing me with that. That's
what winners do you architect?
Like I used to carry boxes
and things of that nature,
but some of the stuff that's
Mundane and D rock will try to
remind me to think of selfie
is I'm going to answer 800
people's email right now
answers the architect here.
You know, what is the conductor?
Is that, what is this called?
The orchestra conductor. Like
what the the conductor do?
Charles, this kid, Charles,
like, what are you doing again,
Charles, the conductor
waves fingers around, right?
that guys playing the violin,
but she she's the conductor.
So while you're still in the trenches,
trying to figure your out,
once you understand what
the is really going on now,
sometimes the conductor's
gotta play the violin.
I'm going to go play the violin
for five and a half hours
and answer very mundane,
deep, very contextual,
very simple dog shit things
that I have to do to get done.
Winners play up here and down here,
obviously like me answering
emails and all that stuff is not
necessarily the most compelling,
but I cannot have a laptop
anymore is a weird thing. Right?
Cause I would feel myself
doing email for you.
I don't have a laptop. I
do everything on my phone.
Can't do both right now. Tech wise,
he rockets yelled that when
he comes to first class,
he's got fancy. He might
get upgraded to first class.
And so we'll see if that happens,
then he can feel me Charles.
And you can see me doing
my fucking emails dickface.
I'm going to turn into my
favorite superhero. Airport Gary.
He goes from normal entrepreneur.
He Charles here's a
sweatshirt for you friend.